here with reaction wisconsin senator ron
johnson uh that in and of itself is a
bombshell that we have whistleblowers
i'd like to hear from them uh are there
i do believe that the vast majority of
rank and file are good people we see the
corruption at the highest levels of the
doj and fbi don't we
we do and you know i'm sure not question
the integrity of most uh members of the
fbi and partner justice but that's what
mayor garland is accusing us of it's a
diversionary tactic on his part you know
in august the whistleblowers told chuck
grassley in august of 2020 the ft fbi
developed a scheme to downplay the
disparaging uh information on hunter
biden to basically deep six it that
exact same month
sunder grass and i received unsolicited
briefings that we both knew were setups
they told us nothing we asked at the
time who directed these briefings two
years later sean we don't know who
direct those briefings and they were set
ups because nine months later those
briefings were leaked to the new york
time or the washington post to smear me
so this corruption has run deep it's
been running deep since the hillary
clinton email scandal remember the uh
the editing of the james comey
exoneration email where they changed
phrases like grossly negligent to cares
extremely careless to avoid the criminal
terminology so
i do not trust uh the fbi don't trust
the upper leg
echelons department of justice uh again
the rank and file those individuals if
you want to see integrity restored to
your agencies you need to come forward
whistleblower ronjohnson.senate.gov
will maintain your anonymity but we need
to talk to you to restore credibility to
your agencies
chris wray could have done the fbi the
greatest service he could have cleaned
up the mess he could have stopped the
lying he could have stopped those people
that were responsible held them
accountable for spreading lies and
misinformation about trump-russia
collusion
he could have stopped the people that
went ahead with and put forward
unverifiable information in a fisa
application to ruin carter page's life
and donald trump's life he hasn't done a
thing that i see to clean up the fbi
does he need to go
well he's done worse than that under his
watch for example when the pfizer report
michael horowitz's prize report was
issued there were footnotes that were
classified that were redacted that
contradicted the body bill precept in
the body of the report said the fbi had
no knowledge that the steele dossier was
tainted by russian disinformation the
footnotes said the exact opposite in
october 2016 january 2017 the fbi knew
that the steele dossier was tainted in
march of 2018 the fbi briefed the senate
intel committee said that steele dossier
had integrity and of course they allowed
the miller probe to go forward so this
is corruption we need to go back we need
to re-examine what we already know and
put it in light of new information for
example the scheme in the fbi to
downplay uh what was happening with
hunter and again i i believe at time i
thought it was just a setup to try and
destroy me politically now i'm starting
to think that maybe that briefing was
all about trying to take us off the
trail trying to dissuade us from even
issuing our report that we issued in
september of 2020
should have
it affected the election but the news
media admitted it or
ignored it
we know there's evidence of crimes on
hunter's laptop chris ray's had it for
two years what does that say about equal
justice not very much to me but senator
uh thank you for being with us your race
also is pivotal come november uh and i
know you're going to do well in
wisconsin thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else